[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez on m'a fait évidemment avec
françois-xavier avec hervé avec tous les
candidats de la liste beaucoup de
meetings mais ici c'est au verbe
rhône-alpes et évidemment pour moi il ya
une histoire qui dernière beaucoup de
visages qui sont dans cette salle ce que
je suis devenu je le dois beaucoup
d'entre vous les convictions que je
porte
énergie que je peux avoir c'est celle
que vous me donnez et vous savez que je
m'emploie toujours à veiller à ce que
vous ne soyez jamais trahi que vous ne
soyez pas trahi dans ce qu'on fait dans
notre région que nous avons gagnés sur
la gauche et sans la moindre alliance ou
petits compromis du second tour juste
sur nos valeurs sur nos idées
grâce à bout
sur ce que nous reconstruisons pour
notre famille politique et sur ce que
nous faisons dans cette campagne des
européennes et je le fais parce que j'ai
toujours porté avec vous cette
conviction qu'en politique on ne gagne
jamais en cherchant les petits accords
qu'en politique les seuls choix qui sont
les bons ce sont les choix courageux
exigeant qu'en politique quand on a des
valeurs quand on a des idées quand on a
des convictions il faut avoir le courage
de les affirmer et de les tenir sur la
durée que quand l'on veut rassembler on
ne rassemble jamais sur le plus petit
dénominateur commun
on rassemble sur le respect de ce que
chacun porte en essayant de faire en
sorte qu'on soit complémentaire mais pas
complémentaires sur la trahison de nos
idées ce que nous avons beaucoup trop
pratiqué par le passé mais
complémentaires au contraire sur
l'affirmation de ce que chacun apporte
pourquoi est-ce que je suis extrêmement
fier de ce que françois xavier a
construit de ce qu'hervé nous a apporté
de ce que chacun des colistiers amené
dans cette campagne des européennes
parce que si vous vous y prêtez
attention nous avons posé tous les
jalons qui nous porterons dans l'avenir
et je voudrais vraiment devant vous dire
à quel point je suis reconnaissant à
françois-xavier de ce qui l'a amené dans
cette campagne de la hauteur qu'il a
apporté de sa capacité à retisser vers
le haut a redonné des idées une colonne
vertébrale pas attirés vers la politique
vers le bas comme elle s'abîme dans ces
successions de buzz médiatique mais au
contraire essayer de redonner de la
hauteur des idées de la profondeur il
n'a pas seulement apporté du
rajeunissement
il n'a pas seulement apporté une
nouvelle génération il a apporté
beaucoup plus il a dit à tous ceux qui
avaient des convictions dans ce pays
ne baissez pas le regard redresser le
regard c'est comme cela que l'on se fait
entendre
et cela nous l'avons fait en rassemblant
regarder l'image
qu'apporte nos familles politiques ce
soir le droite la droite et le centre
sont unis et je remercie hervé de sa
confiance
oui et toi qui nous défend souvent en
face à un pouvoir beaucoup trop
centralisateur ici nous sommes une
région on n'aime pas tellement que ce
soit paris qui nous demande toi qui
défend avec acharnement
face à un président de la république qui
voudraient tout commander depuis
quelques ministères l'autonomie de nos
territoires
toi qui as incarnés nous a fait
confiance pour planter ses fondations
qu'ils nous porteront sur les batailles
à venir
nous avons ensemble poser les bases de
ce qui nous portera jusqu'à la prochaine
présidentielle
les bases de cette alliance de la droite
et du centre dans laquelle le centre
n'est pas le nom d'un vide dans lequel
le centre n'est pas assez succession de
trahison qui ont été portées par
françois bayrou
mais dans lequel le centre est fidèle à
son histoire politique qui est celle du
centre-droit
et ce soir nous sommes tous rassemblés
et j'aime cette image dans une région où
ici personne n'a trahi dans laquelle ou
ici il n'y a pas eu ce qui se sont
vendus nous avons tous rester fidèle à
ce qui était la grande histoire de la
droite et le centre en auvergne
rhône-alpes et je veux remercier ici
tous ceux qui nous aident à la bâtir au
quotidien vous me permettrait de
commencer par mes conseillers régionaux
à travers philippe et le courage et la
droiture qui l'incarnent
j'aime philippe parce que quand je dois
monter à l'assaut des tranchées je sais
qu'il est toujours à mes côtés
merci à tous les conseillers régionaux
qui sont ici merci à toi philippe nos
départements qui sont là ils savent à
quel point je tiens à ce que nous
puissions travailler ensemble en
confiance marie pierre qui est notre
présidente du département de la drôme
courageuse et déterminée
christophe avec lequel on a une histoire
d'amitié qui est si longue et bruno le
petit dernier qui vient du fin fond du
cantal et pour lequel il faut quatre à
cinq heures de route pour venir nous
rejoindre le cantal ce petit poucet que
j'aime tant moment nos parlementaires
qui sont ici toute la région et autour
également notre voisine de franche-comté
annie genevard c'est l'union des
parlementaires députés et sénateurs qui
sont là nos mères et je veux rendre
hommage et ils se reconnaîtront à
travers les deux qui sont ici d'une part
à michel dantin qui a sans doute été un
des députés européens les plus reconnus
au tour de la précédente mandature et
qui a fait le choix de la fidélité à sa
ville de chambéry
michel c'est un homme trempé et j'aime
ça mais il sait aussi que moi les
agriculteurs comptons sur lui pour
pouvoir continuer à exercer des
fonctions à nos côtés auprès de la
commission européenne et j'en ai déjà
parlé à montrer de bébert michel tu sais
qu'il y à beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
veulent que tu continues à défendre la
place de l'agriculture pour les cinq ans
qui sont devant nous michel tu auras un
double travail
chambéry et l'agriculture au sein des
républicains et de l'union de la droite
et du centre
et le deuxième au calme me rendre
hommage ici en y associant évidemment
etienne blanc c'est la présence de denis
broliquier je remercie denis de sa
présence parce qu'il marque le
rassemblement de notre famille politique
au dernier meeting dans marche
gérard collomb n'avait pas souhaité se
déplacer marquant ainsi les divisions
qui sont en train de laminer tout ce
qu'ils ont sur lyon et la métropole
nous nous offrons l'image d'une famille
politique qui est rassemblée sur lyon
sur le rhône et sur la totalité de notre
région merci à vous merci de cette image
alors mes amis le président de la
république son premier ministre
sa tête de liste pour les élections
européennes qu'il s'évertue à cacher le
plus possible n'ont de cesse dans cette
campagne que de faire étalage de leur
mépris pour ceux qui ne pensent pas
comme eux dernièrement encore la semaine
dernière le premier ministre s'en est
pris à ce qu'il appelle la droite
trocadéro en expliquant qu'il n'aimait
pas la droite trocadéro
[Musique]
mes amis ne le siffle et pas parce que
quand il dit cela il dit en réalité
quelque chose de très profond pour lui
ce n'est pas la droite trocadéro qu'il
n'aime pas c'est la droite tout court
qu'il n'aime pas et ils n'aiment pas la
droite tout court parce que il n'ya rien
de droite dans les convictions qu'il
porte
il n'y a rien de droite dans ce qu'ils
font il n'y a rien de droite dans la
vision qu'ils portent pour la france et
pour l'europe
quand il dit qu'il n'aime pas la droite
trocadéro ce qu'il signale juste c'est
que c'est ouvert une immense déception
entre des gens qui lui avaient fait
confiance et qui aujourd'hui au bout de
deux ans s'aperçoivent que ce
gouvernement ne correspond pas que ce
président de la république ne correspond
pas à ce que sont les attentes des
français qui partage les convictions de
la droite et du centre
parce que quand on est de droite on a le
courage de baisser la dépense publique
et de réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires alors qu'il a continué à
l'augmenter encore l'année dernière
à l'inversé total de ce que nous avons
fait nous dans notre région
quand on est de droite on ne nie pas
l'existence d'une culture française et
on ne rabaisse pas notre pays en allant
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
expliqué que nous n'aurions commis que
des crimes contre l'humanité en algérie
quand on est de droite
on ne confond pas le voile islamique est
le fils hugues aurait soi-disant porter
nos grands mères à l'église comme le
fait madame l'oiseau en expliquant qu'il
n'y a pas de différence entre les deux
quand on est de droite
on a du respect pour nos aînés et on ne
prend pas huit milliards d'euros sur le
dos du pouvoir d'achat de nos retraités
en moins de deux ans en expliquant que
les retraités français seraient des
privilégiés
quand on est de droite on ne délivre par
un record de titres de séjour a toujours
plus d'immigrés alors que nos capacités
d'intégration sont dépassés jamais la
france n'a délivré autant de titres de
séjour que depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron
quand on est de droite on ne compare pas
un terroriste palestinien à nelson
mandela comme l'a fait pascal durand qui
est en position éligible sur la liste
dans marche
je me battrai toujours pour que
l'antisémitisme sous toutes ses formes
s'installe à l'intérieur de notre pays
et je le dis dans cette ville de
villeurbanne ou parfois des élèves juifs
n'ont malheureusement plus le choix des
activités périscolaires qu'ils peuvent
pratiquer parce qu'ils sont soumis à des
pressions et même à des menaces sur leur
sécurité ici dans la république
française
ça n'est pas acceptable ça ne peut pas
être seul à l'avenir de la république et
de la transe et quand on est de droite
oui on n'est pas soutenue tout à la fois
par daniel cohn bendit
elisabeth guigou et ségolène royal pour
tous ceux qui ont des convictions de
droite et du centre cela doit amener à
beaucoup de prudence quand on regarde
une liste en mars daniel cohn bendit
ségolène royal et elisabeth guigou
ça ressemble furieusement à la majorité
plurielle de lionel jospin
alors il ya bien un choix à faire dans
cette élection pour la refondation de
l'europe ce choix et vous savez à quel
point je me bats contre ce chemin qui
serait un chemin funès pour notre pays
ça ne peut en aucun cas être celui de
marine le pen et du rassemblement
national
ce que propose marine le pen c'est la
déconstruction de l'europe ce que
propose marine le pen c'est la
déconstruction de l'euro et il suffit de
regarder de l'autre côté de la manche
pour voir ce qui se passe dans un pays
quand on écoute les mêmes discours que
ce que tient marine le pen
il suffit de voir ce qui est en train de
se passer de l'autre côté des alpes
en italie où l'idole de marine le pen
monsieur salvini est en train petit à
petit d'amener l'économie euros
italienne au bord du ko avec une chute
dramatique de leur taux de croissance un
appauvrissement des italiens et une
montée du taux de chômage
je refuserai toujours le chemin de
marine le pen pour l'europe parce que je
crois profondément que ce chemin serait
une erreur historique pour notre pays
nous n'avons jamais eu autant besoin de
l'europe face à la chine face aux états
unis face aux défis de l'immigration
massive et elle voudrait nous en faire
sortir et prenez garde
parce que dans cette campagne il ya
quelque chose qui s'est révélé j'ai vu
petit à petit se rapprocher des bas
après débat les positions de l'extrême
gauche et de l'extrême droite
nous avons vu nous dans notre région
même un conseiller régional qui était
avant de la france insoumise et qui
s'est mis à apporter son soutien à
marine le pen
c'est toujours un signe ce signe de
l'alliance des extrêmes n'est jamais une
bonne nouvelle est en tout cas il
signale une chose marine le pen n'est
pas de droite
elle est juste extrême elle est juste
extrême elle n'est pas de droite
mais cette voie ça n'est pas non plus
celle d' emmanuel macron lui dont
l'europe philippe tu l'a rappelé et
l'europe de l'élargissement c'est
l'europe du multiculturalisme c'est
l'europe de l'immigration non maîtrisée
c'est l'europe de la technocratie et des
impôts
aujourd'hui le président de la
république est à nouveau intervenue dans
la campagne et l'interview qu'il a donné
dans la presse régionale nous rappelle à
quel point la vision qu'il porte pour
l'europe ne correspond pas aux valeurs
de la droite et du centre en un seul
entretien il est parvenu à proposer
trois taxes supplémentaires
une taxe sur les entreprises une taxe
carbone est une taxe sur le kérosène ce
qui signifierait que demain tous les
billets d'avion serait plus cher
3i des trois taxes un président qui peut
déjà s'enorgueillir d'avoir le record en
europe de la dépense publique et des
impôts et qui à chaque fois qu'il fait
une proposition fait une proposition de
taxe supplémentaire
la seule contribution des manuels macron
au débat européen
c'est sa créativité fiscale dont aucun
autre pays en europe ne veut et il a
d'ailleurs annoncé au niveau européen
qu'il souhaitait faire alliance avec les
socialistes et notamment avec la gauche
portugaise et italienne
mais comment ne pas voir surtout à quel
point en deux ans il a fracturé l'europe
il nous a mis à dos les pays d'europe
centrale en leur faisant la leçon il a
abîmé l'amitié franco allemande
il nous a aliéné par son comportement
tout à la fois les pays du sud et les
pays scandinaves
tous les présidents français s'était
employé à fédérer lui à diviser et à
fracturer la dislocation de l'europe
il en est depuis deux ans l'acteur et je
le dis à tous les français qui veulent
refonder l'europe ce n'est pas en votant
pour emmanuel macron
qu'on y parviendra parce qu'avec ce
président jammeh la voix de la france
n'a été aussi isolé sur la scène
européenne
quand nicolas sarkozy s'était engagé
c'était pour sauver l'europe dans cette
campagne
quand emmanuel macron s'engage c'est
juste pour se sauver lui même et rien de
plus et rien de plus et bien mes amis je
le dis à tous les français qui sont
déçus par ce qui a été fait depuis deux
ans tout le monde a compris que voter
pour en marche c'était faire un chèque
en blanc à emmanuel macron et je leur
dis vous avez le choix
vous pouvez voter en fonction de vos
convictions et vous n'êtes pas condamné
à voter pour les extrêmes et je
m'adresse à tous les français qui
croient dans les valeurs de la droite et
du centre
c'est le moment de faire entendre votre
voix c'est le moment de vous exprimer il
y à une liste qui croient dans l'europe
et qui portent nos valeurs une europe
qui protège nos frontières une europe
des projets une europe qui défendent
notre identité commune et nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes face à l'islamisme
l'europe que nous aimons cette liste
c'est la seule qui peut défendre ses
valeurs au parlement européen
il y a une seule liste dans cette
campagne européenne qui apporte une
alternative entre un président de la
république qui a déçu et le chaos des
extrêmes cette liste c'est la liste des
républicains c'est la liste de l'union
de la droite et du centre
c'est la liste portée par françois
xavier bellamy
refonder l'europe
que font les pères fondateurs quand ils
choisissent un symbole comme est il sur
ce drapeau bleu il met les étoiles de la
couronne de la vierge que font de gaulle
et adenauer
quant au lendemain des atrocités de la
guerre ils choisissent de marquer la
réconciliation franco-allemande ne vont
pas à paris ils ne vont pas à berlin ils
ne vont pas à bruxelles ils vont devant
la cathédrale de reims
devant cette statue de l'ange au sourire
qui avait été dévasté par les obus
allemands et ils choisi ce lieu qui est
l'incarnation même du franco allemande
et que font-ils mais ce qu'ils font
c'est un projet de civilisation
ils ne font pas d'abord une construction
administrative
ils ne font pas d'abord la commission
européenne ils ne font pas d'abord
l'union européenne ils font d'abord un
projet de civilisation
ils veulent dire quelque chose au monde
la voix de l'europe n'est pas éteinte
nous avons quelque chose à dire
pourquoi êtes vous là pourquoi avez vous
été aussi nombreux tout au long de cette
campagne parce que nous portons ensemble
la même volonté parce que nous portons
ensemble la même interrogation parce que
nous refusons ensemble de nous dire
notre mode de vie est condamné a changé
de nature
nous serions condamnés à renoncer à tout
ce que nous sommes
non nous voulons tous linverse nous
voulons au contraire pouvoir transmettre
à notre famille je veux pouvoir
transmettre à mes deux enfants est
louise et baptiste qui sont là et dont
je suis si fier c'est important parfois
qu'un père puisse dire à ses enfants
à quel point il est fier d'eux
eh bien je veux demain que eux aussi ils
connaissent ils chérissent cette
civilisation nous avons reçu et je veux
qu'on puisse à notre tour leur
transmettre ce bien qui est si précieux
et oui quand on nous interroge autour de
cette campagne sur l'europe que nous
voulons
eh bien nous répondons simplement
l'europe que nous voulons oui c'est
l'europe de l'identité c'est l'europe de
la civilisation c'est l'europe des
racines parce que nous sommes convaincus
avec françois-xavier que pour pouvoir
pousser pour pouvoir grandir il faut
avoir quelque chose sur lequel s'adosser
s'appuyer et dans lequel on puise la
force d'avancer une civilisation quand
romulus traces le périmètre de rome
il trace un sillon une frontière parce
qu'il veut marquer que c'est lui qui
décidera qui a le droit d'entrer ou de
ne pas entrer à l'intérieur de la cité
qu'il a fondé vous voulez une
civilisation il faut commencer par
tracer une frontière non nous ne pouvons
pas continuer à avoir une europe qui
s'élargit sans fin oui l'élargissement a
sans doute été une des pires décisions
que nous ayons pris au cours des
dernières années parce que
l'élargissement non maîtrisé et aboutit
à affaiblir de l'intérieur l'union
européenne emmanuel macron a dit à
trieste qu'il voulait l'élargissement le
plus rapide possible au pays des balkans
il a dit à bucarest qu'il voulait
l'entrée de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie le plus rapidement possible à
l'intérieur de schengen et nous nous
disons avec la plus grande fermeté tous
nos candidats l'ont signé il s'engage à
voter pendant les cinq ans contre toute
décision qui ouvrirait la voie à des
élargissements supplémentaires et là on
arrête définitivement les négociations
avec la turquie
car la turquie ne sera jamais un pays
européen
se fixer des frontières mais ensuite il
faut les défendre
nous sommes tous nécessairement touché
choqué parfois par les images de ces
drames que nous voyons en mer
méditerranée par ces visages qui ont
parfois beaucoup souffert poussée par de
faux espoirs à tout risquer c'est être
déraciné auquel on a fait miroiter un
eldorado de l'autre côté en europe
qu'ils ne trouveront pas et je pose
cette question simple est ce cela la
générosité est ce cela la générosité que
d'être complice des passeurs en laissant
naître de faux espoirs
est ce cela la générosité que de faire
croire que l'avenir de l'afrique peut
être en europe
est ce que la vraie générosité ça n'est
pas au contraire de dire que l'avenir de
la jeunesse africaine doit être en
afrique
est ce que la vraie générosité ça n'est
pas de se battre pour aider à développer
l'afrique faire en sorte d' intensifier
et de les accompagner dans le
développement de leur appareil de
formation dans la croissance de leur
économie
et là l'europe a une responsabilité
faire en sorte que le continent africain
puisse se développer mais en fixant
aussi clairement les règles
emmanuel macron veut que nous ouvrions
de nouveaux centres pour traiter les
demandeurs d'asile en europe nous nous
disons que les demandes doivent être
faite de l'autre côté de la méditerranée
parce que quand les gens arrivent sur le
sol européen
c'est trop tard nous nous disons
contrairement à ce que fait ce
gouvernement que les bateaux des
passeurs doivent être reconduits de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée alors
que la france a accepté systématiquement
de prendre les migrants qui venait des
bateaux des passeurs sur le sol français
et nous nous disons clairement que quand
quelqu'un est rentré illégalement en
europe
il faut fixer une règle simple il ne
pourra plus jamais être régularisés
parce que vous ne rentrez pas dans la
maison de quelqu'un en fracturant la
porte et la fenêtre vous rentrez en
demandant l'autorisation de pouvoir vous
asseoir autour de la table commune pour
qu'il ya une civilisation il faut qu'il
y ait des frontières
mais pour qu'il y ait une civilisation
il faut aussi autre chose il faut qu'il
y ait des projets en commun
il faut qu'il y ait les ambitions
communes il faut qu'il y ait des choses
à porter ensemble nous avons parfois
trop abîmés l'europe avec les normes
ces normes dont tocqueville expliqué
qu'elle énerve et qu'elle est bête
nous n'avons pas fait attention que
petit à petit cette europe si belle qui
s'était incarné dans des projets si
magnifique s'est abîmé avec les normes
et surtout nous n'avons pas pris garde à
ce que notre pays qui se croient parfois
tellement plus intelligent que les
autres n'a fait que rajouter des normes
aux normes et que bien souvent nous
sommes responsables quand les français
disent mais comment avez vous pu faire
de telles inepties retrouvons le bon
sens et comme le disait un président de
notre région arrêtez d'emmerder les
français c'est sans doute le président
qui s'exprimait dans le langage le plus
évident est le plus beau c'était
pompidou et il aimait la poésie
française
des projets oui le lyon-turin des
projets oui pourquoi pas la couverture
en internet très haut débit de
l'ensemble du continent européen dont la
commission européenne pourrait prendre
la maîtrise d'ouvragé des projets
pourquoi pas pourquoi ne pas se doter de
cette ambition qui pourrait être si
belle pour l'europe que de faire
travailler ensemble tous nos
laboratoires de recherche pour vaincre
la maladie qui est le fléau du xxième
siècle la maladie d'alzheimer les
maladies neurodégénératives
ces maladies terribles qui sont tout à
la fois une épreuve physique
psychologique et moral quand on perd
l'être qu'on a aimé et qu'avant même que
la mort ne vienne on a l'impression
d'être privés de la possibilité juste
d'échangés et qu'elle arrive et ne reste
plus que cette dernière parcelle
d'humanité qui est l' échange du regard
dont parlait si bien le philosophe
levinas la maladie d'alzheimer est sans
doute une des plus grandes épreuves
qu'une famille puisse connaître comme
j'aimerais que pour les cinq ans qui
viennent
l'europe se dote de cette grande cause
européenne et que nous puissions revenir
demain en dix ans nous appartenons au
continent qui a permis de trouver les
réponses face aux maladies
neurodégénératives cette europe c'est
l'europe du travail et françois-xavier
on parlera une europe qui doit assumer
de défendre nos produits et notre
agriculture notamment face à la chine
mais l'europe du travail cela signifie
aussi que chez nous tout ne peut pas
être marchandisé cela signifie que chez
nous on ne peut pas devenir un continent
vont pousser caddie dans des
supermarchés ou plus rien n'a été
produit chez nous et cela signifie
surtout qu en europe tout n'est pas à
acheter et à vendre le corps humain la
dignité de la personne humaine y compris
dans la question de la procréation ne
peut pas être altéré ne peut pas être
changé
la tête de liste dans marche défend et
c'est son droit et je vous demande de le
respecter
la légalisation des mères porteuses ce
qu'on appelle la gestation pour autrui
mais il faut bien comprendre qu'à
travers elle le risque c'est que tous
ceux qui se battent pour faire en sorte
que ce soit les position favorable à la
gestation pour autrui qui l'emportent en
passant par bruxelles pour ensuite venir
s'imposer dans notre pays à travers elle
c'est toutes ces positions qui ferait
leur entrée en force au parlement
européen et bien je peux respecter je
peux demander qu'on insulte pas sa
position
mais surtout je combats cette position
parce que je ne peux me résigner
ce n'est pas ma conception de ce qu'est
la civilisation européenne
ça n'est pas ma conviction de ce qu'est
l'éthique de ce que petit à petit toute
notre culture a produit pour dire qu'il
ya des limites à la science qu'il y a
des limites au tout pouvoir de l'être
humain que l'homme ne peut pas devenir
un dieu et que nous devons veiller plus
que tout à faire en sorte de ne pas
altérer l'éthique et le respect profond
que nous devons à la dignité humaine
nous nous battrons pour faire interdire
au niveau européen la marchandisation du
corps humain
nous nous battrons contre cela
et une civilisation enfin c'est savoir
qui nous sommes
c'est chérir notre culture notre
identité c'est la protéger comme notre
bien le plus précieux contre ceux qui
veulent la détruire
aujourd'hui l'islamisme est la menace la
plus dangereuse qui pèse sur l'europe
entière et l'europe de se fixer une
priorité vaincre le totalitarisme
islamique marine le pen déteste
tellement l'europe que même quand c'est
dans notre intérêt que l'europe agisse
et nous protègent elles votent contre
l'europe avait proposé de mettre en
place un logiciel permettant de
s'assurer que des terroristes ne
puissent pas monter dans des avions
madame le pen signant son
irresponsabilité ces caricatures et ses
excès a voté contre en expliquant que
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
mais comment un responsable politique
peut dire de telles stupidités
après les attentats du 11 septembre
après mohamed merah après les faire
kouassi qui sont allés évidemment en
afghanistan et au yémen
en prenant l'avion madame le pen vous
êtes irresponsables et on ne pourra
jamais vous confiez ni les destinées de
la france ni les destinées de l'europe
et de l'autre côté emmanuel macron et la
liste dans marche n'en parle même pas
vous pouvez regarder leurs programmes du
début à la fin il n'y a pas un mot sur
l'islamisme
eh bien nous nous en parlons et bien
nous nous voulons agir et nous
souhaitons faire de l'europe un rempart
contre l'islamisme et nous proposons un
pacte européen qui permette enfin de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent la
première mesure qui s'impose il faut
fermer toutes les mosquées salafistes
qui sont en europe pour faire s'arrêter
le travail de propagation de m sur le
continent européen
nous nous proposons des mesures claires
ici dans cette région vous le savez j'ai
refusé de financer un soi-disant
institut culturel musulman qui était en
réalité payés par des puissances
étrangères et qui ne nous apportait
aucune garantie d'indépendance et enfin
il faut traiter sérieusement la question
des jihadistes yannick philippe etienne
vous vous êtes rendu en irak
vous avez vu le programme de soutien que
nous menons avec la fondation mérieux à
laquelle je veux rendre hommage pour
toutes les minorités chrétienne en
orient qui sont opprimés
et vous avez vu ce que j'ai vu aussi
quand je suis allé à mossoul
vous avez vu le visage de ces familles
zidi transformer en esclaves sexuels par
des militants des ch qui se les
revendait après les avoir violées vous
avez vu ces familles qui parfois au
coeur de mossoul avait perdu tous leurs
enfants tués assassinés avec la pire
sauvagerie juste parce qu'ils ne
partageaient pas la même religion
vous avez vu ces ruines fumantes dans la
plaine de qaraqosh où les quelques
villages chrétiens avaient été
exterminés et miné consciencieusement
tout cela c'est l'oeuvre de la barbarie
de dèche et des djihadistes emmanuel
macron et le gouvernement n'a rien fait
pour s'opposer au retour de dizaines de
jihadistes sur le sol français ce n'est
pas responsable ce n'est pas responsable
nous ce que nous demandons c'est que
l'europe prenne la responsabilité
d'organiser un tribunal international en
irak que les djihadistes soit jugé là où
ils ont commis leur crime qu'il soit
condamné là où ils ont commis leur crime
et qu'il reste là où ils ont commis leur
crime ils n'ont plus rien à faire sur le
sol français et sur le sol européen
[Applaudissements]
et dans cette vie existe il y a des
enfants qui sont nés en france il y a
des enfants qui sont nés en europe il ya
les enfants qui ont tous reçu de la
france et de l'europe et qui ont tourné
leur peine et comment ne pas
s'interroger sur cette question simple
que s'est il passé
souvenez vous souvenez vous de ce qu'est
l'histoire de l'intégration républicaine
cette histoire merveilleuse dont je suis
sûr que nous pourrions être nombreux ici
a témoigné cette histoire qui faisaient
que des familles venant d'italie venant
d'espagne venant du portugal
venant de pologne venant d'arménie
venant du sud de la méditerranée
venette en france en dix ans à leurs
enfants
à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est la
france ne fait pas honte apprend le
français à l'école respecte tes maîtres
ne te fait pas remarquer fait en sorte
de calais ton mode de vie sur ceux qui
sont nos voisins ton pays c'est la
france ça c'est la magie de ce qu'est
l'intégration républicaine et qu'avons
nous fait mais tout simplement nous
avons inversé le devoir d'intégration
nous avons petit à petit cru qu'à
cueillir celui qui venait de l'étranger
au lieu de lui expliquer ce qu'était le
mode de vie du pays qu'il avait choisi
et du continent qu'il avait choisi nous
avons cru que c'était à nous de nous
adapter à celui qui venait de l'étranger
et on a bâti tout seul à la tolérance et
au nom de cette tolérance si mal
comprises au lieu d'avoir la générosité
de transmettre et d'expliquer ce que
nous sommes nous avons cru que c'était
nous qui devions nous adapter à celui
qui venait de l'étranger
et petit à petit nous avons laissé se
perdre notre mode de vie et nous avons
laissé petit à petit ses frites et cette
république merveilleuse qui a été
capable d'intégrer pendant des dizaines
d'années et nous avons laissé le
communautarisme s'intégrer et à
l'arrivée qu'est ce que cela produit est
ce que cela produit l'intégration de
ceux qui arrivent chez nous tout au
contraire cela produit des ghettos cela
produit de l'isolément cela produit du
malheur cela aboutit à ce que les
musulmans modérés deviennent petit à
petit sous la coupe est sous le joug des
musulmans intégristes qui pousse sans
cesse un peu plus loin le pion parce
qu'ils sont qu'en face nous avons décidé
de nous soumettre
et bien moi je n'ai pas décidé de me
soumettre
moi je refuse de voir mon pays
j'ai de nature moi je crois dans la
beauté de ce qu'est notre mode de vie et
de ce qu'est notre culture
comment ne pas le comprendre quand on a
vu brûler notre dame
alors nous avons tous ressenti cette
évidence c'est la france qui brûle parce
que évidemment que la france a des
racines de l'antiquité
parce que évidemment que la france a des
racines des lumières mais aussi la
france que l'on soit chrétien ou que
l'on ne soit pas que l'on soit croyant
ou qu'on ne soit pas notre dame c'est la
france parce que la france a des racines
chrétiennes et que ses racines
chrétiennes ont forgé notre identité est
ce qu'il y a de plus beau dans le
message de notre civilisation et bien
prenez y garde parce qu'il ya des
incendies que l'on voit et il y à des
incendies invisible à chaque fois que
l'on accepte dans nos écoles que l'on
enseigne plus l'histoire de france 7
un incendie invisible à chaque fois
qu'une minorité au nom de tel ou tel
droit à la différence
impose ses pratiques communautaires au
lieu de faire siennes les valeurs de la
république
7 un incendie invisible à chaque fois
qu'une femme n'a plus le choix de la
profession qu'elle veut prendre ou de la
manière dont elle s'habille 7
un incendie invisible à chaque fois que
dans un service public à l'image de ce
qui se passe en ce moment à grenoble on
cherche à revenir sur la mixité
on cherche à imposer le burqini dans le
mépris de nos règlements
7 un incendie invisible pourquoi
pourquoi et vous le savez ici j'ai
toujours refusé de reculer sur la
question des crèches
parce que les crèches c'est un petit
bout futile symbolique de ce que nous
sommes et qu'à chaque fois que l'on
trahit ou que l'on recule sur un petit
bout de ce que nous sommes
cette un grand beau de ce que nous
serons demain que nous abandonnons je
refuse que nous continuions à reculer je
veux que nous retrouvions la fierté de
notre histoire et c'est par cela mes
amis que je veux finir ici dans cette
terre qui nous a portés et qui est si
riche par son histoire et sa géographie
cette fierté c'est celle de cette europe
millénaire qui nous a enfanté ici la
silhouette des montagnes incite à se
dépasser
ici le passé de l'antiquité à le
prestige de la capitale des gaules
ici la terre depuis le monastère de brou
en passant par l'arthrose ou les chemins
de saint jacques s'est couverte de
clocher et dhabi qui nous honore ici la
culture de la renaissance a fait se
rencontrer l'europe du nord et la
culture italienne pour produire sans
doute ce qu'il ya de plus beau en europe
dans cette rencontre entre ces deux
traditions qui nous ont ensuite porté
jusqu'à l'europe des lumières avec la
foi dans le progrès dans la science est
dans l'homme ici les héros s'appellent
louise labé voltaire et stendhal
parce que quand on est un pays comme la
france on ne chérit pas seulement ses
généraux on chérit ses hommes de lettres
qui nous honore à travers le temps ici
les aventuriers ont le panache de la
fayette de saint-exupéry et les frères
lumière ici le vin à la générosité des
pierres dorées et de la vallée du rhône
ici on a réinventé la gastronomie avec
bocuse est ici les entreprises ne porte
pas le nom d'un fonds de pension les
entreprises s'appelle meirieu
les entreprises s'appelle michelin et
elle porte le nom de fonds et de
familles qui sont attachés à leur
territoire
ici l'histoire est une fierté et c'est
une promesse d'avenir ici c'est l'europe
et la france
ici plus qu'ailleurs nous savons qu'il
faut être fier de son identité et de son
histoire parce que ses racines sont la
meilleure promesse de l'avenir alors ici
mes amis alors que nous sommes sur la
fin de campagne
je veux vous le dire nous avons besoin
de vous françois xavier a besoin de vous
il y a un espoir qui a commencé à
renaître pour notre famille politique
dans cette campagne demain ce sera une
force que personne n'arrêtera ce que
nous vous proposons c'est le plus beau
des combats
je n'en connais pas de plus noble en
politique refonder l'europe et rétablir
la france vive l'europe et vive la
france
[Applaudissements]